Drive my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
The early morning thing I guess has been successful.
Right?
The day of the,
no,
it's unsuccessful.
Radically unsuccessful.
There's been 17 different people missing weight since you,
Oh really?
Like one or two in the same time.
So we'll then what's this?
Why is that then just because they want to get the edge,
the safety,
safety.
It gives people more time to rehydrate themselves.
But the problem is it gives them less time to lose the weight.
Right?
So if you're starting off early in the morning,
like if your,
if your weigh ins or at four o'clock and you know you're not going to eat all
day,
you're going to lose weight all throughout the day.
But if your way ins right at eight o'clock in the morning,
when are you getting up?
You're going to lose all that weight.
You know,
you might not,
you might not lose enough weight.
So people are miscalculating.
There's definitely a lot and there's definitely an issue with people cutting too
much weight.
There's definitely an issue with people doing it.
Unhealthy Sunday be punished or penalized even more though,
like I just recently heard Ray Gosling,
30% of his wealth and that's what,
okay,
that's fine.
Beedamon Calvin Gospel when they admit,
yeah,
I haven't really been looking after my died.
What you're a professional athletes signed to the,
the biggest organization in the world.
It shouldn't have be part of the contract that if you're fighting for us that
you have to maintain.
You almost have those I instead of even a random drug tests,
random one random way,
obviously they made Calvin go up to one 85.
Yes,
next fight.
And what's crazy is you looked fucking
insane.
And Tim Kennedy blew his entire Wad trying to take him down and beat him up.
And they earlier the first round,
I mean,
he,
he showed his size advantage,
his strength advantage.
He's a massive,
uh,
like he's a massive powerhouse when it comes to his ground and pound his
Jujitsu.
But Calvin just stayed the course.
So good defense.
And then eventually when he got on his feet,
man way to swift and it's how many times does he wish now three just missed a
bunch of,
he missed against Tyron Woodley and,
and beat him.
And Tyron has a gentleman decided to pass even take his money.
Remember the,
which is a very fucking,
yeah,
ethical and moral move by the champ now the current champ.
So he lost that and I mean there was more than one fight in the past before
that.
When do you say,
okay,
again,
I show good career because he's a great fighter.
Like you say very good.
One 85 so let's hope okay stays.
But if what he misses way to one 85 then you should take a year.
You can,
you know,
put the fear in them and then they,
they really going to do,
I think Calvin should fight at 85 I mean I think he could,
when he could win it 70 I think he can make 70 but he doesn't always make sense.
But you're right.
One I think.
Yeah,
I mean unless he wants to lose a ton of body fat and then try fighting in one 70
you know,
really clean his diet up.
Really going hard on the Giardia.
Donnie hinders does not seem like the same person.
Oh,
what is it?
Because of Thomson wrecking them the way a lot of work.
Cause I heard you say as well,
even the Brighton like physically just not look physically the no,
he doesn't look like he works as hard.
It doesn't look like he is as motivated.
He doesn't look as hungry.
His vaunted knock out.
Power is gone.
Gone,
gone weird.
It's weird.
Yeah.
I wanted it to him and I should a long time ago,
if I was just coaching with his tie,
his left hand to his body and it put him after every workout,
you go three or four rounds on the back,
you know,
just using your right hand.
Can you imagine if he developed a right hand on top of that?
Yeah.
I mean because it was 90% was left,
you know you would that,
you know,
now you open a whole new door,
you know and it's an unfair to question someone whether or not they tested
positive for anything.
If they are,
whenever I took anything.
If you haven't tested positive.
So he never tested positive for anything.
So you can't look at it to I don't think he did.
Did he know maybe a diuretic or something?
Maybe.
I have no find out of Johnny Hendricks ever tested positive for something.
I don't think he did.
So you know,
there's a lot of people throwing accusations about him and George St Pierre was
peers.
Do you know what it costs will be like one of the things he said about his last
fight,
he said he'd worked out for four times a week,
week,
a one time,
four times a week.
He's like,
he just was not focused on that fight.
If that's the case,
you've got to get out.
That's why he looks like that.
It has nothing to do with you saw it or anything else.
He just doesn't have the hunger anymore.
That's where you,
you put yourself at great risk,
but also mentally going into the fight.
If you know that is not a guy trained 10 times a week and you've trained for,
what are you going to do with four?
It's just weird that his power went away.
Yes.
I mean he used to make ice crumble.
He's to let me,
when you hit John Fitch and went flying,
Martin Kampmann flying,
went flying.
It was like he had magic in his hands and then all of a sudden it stopped.
Yup.
So what the fuck don't have to be a monkey thing.
And really just ruined him.
Yeah.
He fucked them up.
And you fucked him up and he fucked him up with like using that front leg side
kick and then the front leg round kiss.
What'd he hit?
A Bat?
One to the body.
And then Johnny like black nods his head like you got me and then slap the same
one right up to the face.
Yep.
And that's the thing we would want.
We want to buy.
He makes it,
oh yeah.
Perfectly.
And then it suddenly your hook kick and a question mark again.
It's every time it's a different cake.
Yeah.
Hey,
don't know what's going to come.
Mr [inaudible] and Glenn Berger Talk Shit about him.
All the spinning kicks.
It's a waste of energy.
So,
oh,
for real.
Check this shit out.
I mean,
you don't think it's a coincidence that he will kicked Ellenberger in the head
twice?
Yeah.
I go,
here's your waste of time,
dude.
Right?
Yeah.
It's not,
it's not a waste.
It's some fucking super good at this.
[inaudible]
okay.